[Musique]
vous les avez sûrement déjà vu en
pâtisserie asiatiques ces desserts vert
vif ya aucun col à en rajouter c'est
totalement naturelle puis ça devient un
verre caisse - fluo une fois cuit
mélange des eaux et tout ça ça peut être
vert très très très foncée parce que
c'est une herbe tout simplement l'auteur
des livres de cuisine asiatique lilly
nguyen adore le panda ou pandanus qui
fait partie de la famille dépens d'un ac
sa feuille est comestible mais attention
d'autres variétés ne le sont pas ce que
tu vives dame en asie est de plus en
plus en asie
les grands chefs à défaut d'avoir de la
vanne et ont décidé d'utiliser deux par
facture vous faites des crèmes brûlées
un trouvère vous fait des gâteaux un
petit peu vert alors si différents mais
les asiatiques le parlant ça fait partie
de la culture depuis des années pour
tirer profit des saveurs herbacée de
vanille et d'amande
rien de plus simple faudrait les laver
est vrai sont venus peintre
[Musique]
ça fait une couleur magnifique ça fait
une couleur magnifique et ce n'est pas
de l'art this year alors là on tresse
évidemment pour qu'on s'assure d'avoir
tout prix villejust de cette superbe
plante
c'est l'extraction justement du panda et
vous allez mettre dans des glaçons et au
bonheur toujours un moment le
congélateur de prêt pour faire des
dessins
dans la culture laotienne ici le panda
né très utilisé dans les desserts les
seuils manille et dit à l'homme suivent
les traces de leur maire d'auxerre et
ont créé leur boutique de pâtisserie en
ligne
nous on a grandi avec ce lot moi je suis
né là-dedans carrément le mes parents et
on fait ce genre de plus je suis né j'ai
senti cette odeur je connais les
textures des desserts aussi que les gens
aiment ça pour ça qu'on a décidé de
continuer
avec leur mère somail elle prépare
l'extrait panda si on veut avoir le
dessert le plus représentatif et avec
dépendances
ce serait quoi ça serait le nombre
d'armes mais aussi celle de départ
d'anne et le gratuite âgées comme une
simple et plusieurs états pour faire fi
la cuisson c'est une étape à la fois ce
gâteau est composé essentiellement de
farine de riz de tapioca et du sucre
auquel on ajoute de l'essence de panda
ou du lait de coco
[Musique]
le savoir-faire de sommeil ne date pas
d'hier dès l'âge de 9 ans elle
maîtrisait l'art du cannabis à les
laisser robert langdon savone recettes
des coptes comme ahmed voudrait fait que
les mesures c'est pas comme les papiers
lounes au pinceau ingrédients et tout
est correct mais c'est aller au goût
texture a effectué par ses commandants
s'est passé bon ok on essaye d'écrire la
recette mais on sait que ça reste secret
genre pour toujours je suis que dans
tous les partenaires pour loin pour
faire le dessin oui pour réussir son cas
ne sonne ça prend une cuisson à la
vapeur de l'instinct et de la patience
quelques minutes de cuisson pour chacun
des premiers étages puis c'est le hijab
belles montres et pourquoi nombre précis
des taz lamy est avancé comme étage par
étage comme ça comme la ligue qui nous
est tombé parce qu'enfin c'est comme ça
l'utilisation du fan d'ann ne se limite
pas qu'au dessert on le suit cependant
tout même je pense le salé au laos pas
vraiment riche il ya des pays qui
l'utilisent dans le salé peut-être faire
des petits morceaux de poulet dans des
feuilles en fait 2 pendant que vous
voyez peut-être servir en amuse-gueule
le temps d'un apéro normalement à
hambourg et kiel à être mais attention
même qu'il est tout lesquels il est
visuelle et gustative du panda somail à
une mise en garde à vous faire monsieur
n'zi pas trop manger parce que ça ça
fait oublier l'homme pis les moines heat
dimanche pour comme rester très fort
manger mais modérée mois la part ça
cette annonce est ainsi admis comme ça
[Musique]